[Applause]
so
kanye went on rogan you were talking
about some [ __ ] i couldn't finish i
couldn't finish that either but i
watched longer
yeah i got about an hour and a half um
it's
it's you know what's so interesting it's
so hard to call someone who is so much
more successful than you an idiot
but kanye makes it easy yeah you know
what i mean like
he is so much more successful than
everybody in this room but
he's a [ __ ] idiot a rambling
idiot you know what he is to me he's
just bipolar
and he's off his meds and he just
[ __ ] talks and talks and talks
and i love joe i think joe knows how to
handle kanye a lot the one thing i
didn't like was when joe
was like yeah no you're clear you don't
need meds now this guy needs meds yo
and i'm not a [ __ ] mental health
expert but i guess we got a couple
friends that are bothered why are you
acting like kanye's
done this like hasn't done this before
right he has exactly like he's been like
this
i'll tell you what i saw about this and
and i think joe gave him the fairest
shot and maybe i'm biased because i
[ __ ] love
joe yes but i think he gave kanye the
fair shot at explaining himself yeah
and i don't think he explained himself
no do you know what i mean like
this is and al maybe you saw something
different and i really want to hear your
perspective
uh what i saw when i'm watching this
interview
is why kanye loves trump because kanye
can see a con man kanye's a con man
yeah okay okay trump
is a con man they're both brilliant at
the con
okay and they're so good at this one
thing which is part of the con
is convincing people they're great
kanye realized if he just says
i'm the best people just believe that
he's the best
kanye is an unbelievable music producer
nobody's taking that away from him
outside of that i don't know if there's
anything exceptional
the way he's not this i'm not a kanye
fan but the way he has moved fashion
it's insane so fashion
is [ __ ] fair right so fashion
whatever somebody just decides is the
hot thing is the hot thing and this is
how you know fashion is [ __ ] is that
what's really uncool can become cool
in the matter of a week dad shoes are
the most uncool thing then they become
cool
there's no rules to fashion the only
thing that matters in fashion is
the cool person wears it and then it
becomes
it so it's not the way the item looks
it's about who wears it
and kanye has convinced a large swath of
people
that he is a genius and he's done this
simply by saying he's a genius
yeah trump is the exact same way trump
used to say he was a billionaire
before he was ever a billionaire he
would call up
different uh like uh magazines like uh
what are those magazines that cover like
when people go out to parties and [ __ ]
like that oh like esquire lifestyle
lifestyle magazines tabloids he'd call
up tabloids as his apparently as his own
publicist
but not say it was hit me and then he
was billionaire donald trump was at this
party
billionaire donald trump before he was
ever billionaire he made himself a
billionaire
in people's eyes before he was ever a
billionaire in real life and then once
you're a billionaire in people's eyes
it's easy to become the billionaire
because now you're in this you're
sitting down with these other
billionaires
and that is what kanye is a absolute
brilliant genius at and trump is a
genius at too
it's a con but they're genius at the con
and trump was able to build this massive
business that you know when you see
trump on all these buildings
i'm not saying he doesn't own real
estate he owns probably billions of
dollars worth of real estate
but a lot of these buildings are
licensing deals yeah it just says
trump because he's licensing the brand
it's not actually him owning the bill
he's a brilliant con man um
amber said that too though amarosa said
as well said that
what trump says is or how trump is kind
probably sees himself in trump
exactly exactly so i think kanye knows i
ain't the best at designing [ __ ]
i ain't the best at rapping i'm nice as
[ __ ] and music
and and trump loki is probably nice as
[ __ ] when it comes to interpersonal
relationships
i bet you is charming as hell when you
actually meet him and i bet you he can
get
anybody that he's in front of to think
that he's brilliant
and to think that he knows it so much so
that you'll just give him money give him
opportunity give him whatever you want
when he's on tv it's undeniable you got
to watch him entertainment
raw energy tv must see tv anytime he's
on tv
you know what's interesting about the
billionaire thing yep you know what
forbes accuses the kardashians of doing
all the time which is
inflating their net worth they said they
were billionaires long before they were
billionaires and then forbes debunked it
and i think now they are actually are
billionaires or something yeah but like
that's
they said kanye's network was 2.3
billion or something and he was like
yeah no it's higher but whatever guys i
don't know what it is now he's saying
five on joe rogan
yeah what were you going to say so um
what the big takeaway i see from kanye
is that
yeah i don't know what exactly mental
disorder he suffers from
but he's not able to stay on one topic
like his brain just like
jumps around from topic to topic topic
and rogan was there to try to help him
just like bring it back and
focus on one thing but the main overall
message like if you are
trying to stay along with what he's
saying it
it's it's very progressive like he does
think differently than the way we think
yeah because he's bipolar he's mad what
i would say is
but he's been successful doing the
things
when he was progressive yep so it's like
it's very hard to criticize someone
who's more successful than you it's very
difficult so i understand everything i
say just tell me to shut the [ __ ] up
because he's a billionaire i'm not
the [ __ ] do i know okay that being said
the reason why he switches topics in my
opinion is because he ran out of
[ __ ] to spew on that topic
this is the typical kanye conversation
listen so when i'm thinking about
designing
uh you know sneakers i went back to this
very famous pianist uh
jacques van blaud have you heard of
jacqueline black of course you haven't
heard of shock mobile because none of us
have heard of [ __ ] joker have you
heard of jacqueline
well yeah he once he wrote this one
symphony when he was on his bed
so i was thinking about a shoe that
would kind of fit a bed and then i
realized that beds the most important
thing about beds is sleep you know how
valuable sleep is
you know a sleep doctor named timothy
pancakes he did this one study on sleep
are you familiar with the study
no of course you're not nobody so he
just speaks about how many hours you
need it's actually only three but then
they killed him so you don't actually
know the truth
so it's just he just he's like wikipedia
less than wikipedia level knowledge
you can just jump to link bounces it's a
lily pad he's bouncing to the next
little because he can't stay on that
lily pad longer because it will expose
who he is
who else talks like that trump who else
never finishes a sentence no you pointed
that out you're like yeah the subtitles
one of one of trump's clips on instagram
it's it's unbelievable bro how would you
describe it i mean
it's like a ai like computer generated
conversation
i mean like it's just random words just
spew now there's no sentence structure
nothing it just keeps on going and
without subtitles it's the most
entertaining thing you've ever listened
to
with the subtitles you're like i don't
know if this guy knows how to finish the
sentence
but now it's like how do you knock a
person who says crazy [ __ ] hey i'm gonna
do this crazy thing you were looking at
him like you're [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then does the crazy thing yeah
like there's nothing he hasn't said
you're crazy yeah but there's nothing he
said that
he was to do that he had i remember that
we i would push back on that i think
i think 99 of things that he says that
he's going to do
he hasn't done like oh i'm going to
create a sustainable community
i don't see this in the process of doing
it like
so far the only thing that he's done is
made sneakers and sweaters
and made great music outside of that
people were clowning them for the
fashion [ __ ] like when he was came out
with his shirts early on they're like
he's charging a hundred fashion is a con
though and i do agree with that right
yeah sure but like they were calling him
an idiot when it first came out and they
were like you're so stupid you're
selling these shirts for 100 bucks it
just looks like it has holes in it
remember that
but then it turned into the thing and
now people try to get and i will say
that like
the fact the fashion industry is just
frauds sure
like everybody there's a fraud and they
know it's a house of cards right they
just know wherever the popularity lies
we're going to gravitate that way like
these sneakers are cool everybody makes
a version of those sneakers this shirt
is cool everybody makes a version of
that shirt right you can literally see
it happen it's like
balenciaga does something with sneakers
and all of a sudden six months later
zara has the version of it that is kind
of a knock off and so does skechers
right like right now literally right now
valenciaga is making
expensive sketchers all right guys we're
gonna take a break for a second because
i gotta make sure you're using secure
internet okay i got to make sure that
you're using
every sliver that the internet has to
offer all right if you don't have a vpn
you are not accessing everything you
possibly can yeah you got netflix in
america but you want those shows that
are only on netflix uk
and it's not just british shows it's
other shows that for whatever reason
aren't just on that
uk netflix you can get that as long as
you have a vpn
okay you're gonna use surfsharkvpn to do
that this is a no-brainer get the most
of the internet
for almost nothing it's an absolute
bargain right now matter of fact you can
get 83
off but let me just tell you exactly
what you're getting all right 30-day
money-back guarantee you get your money
back if you don't like it
clean web surf in a clean cyber space
ocean no ads
trackers malware or fishing attempts
unlimited devices
take all your devices put it on it no
problem no borders mode that's what i
was talking about right there internet
should be open to everyone so this mode
allows to successfully use surfshark
restricted uh even in restricted regions
okay
you also have the camouflage mode and
that makes sure that even your internet
provider can't tell you're using a vpn
this is on some real secret [ __ ] you
stay private as always
watch any of your favorite movies or
shows on streaming devices
that are only available in certain
countries you know you've been abroad
you want to just pop on espn and see
some sports stuff and they're like oh
this video is not allowed in this
country you don't have to deal with that
if you have a vpn so this is what you're
going to do
limited time only 83 off a two-year plan
and three extra months for free at surf
shock at surf shark dot
deal flagrant okay 83 off
all you got to do and remember three
extra months all you got to do is go to
surfshark.deals
flagrant simple as that this special
offer makes your subscription just 2.21
cents per month
so you can browse securely on all your
devices that's way cheaper than just
buying up netflix in every different
country which you wouldn't even be able
to do because of the restrictions of the
internet so
again you go to surf shark dot deal
flagrant and
make sure you get it 83
off right now go go go let's get back to
the clip
thank you with the broken bags take that
for one second we'll get into burke in a
second but think about that for a second
sketchers the sneakers none of us in
this room would be caught dead wearing
became popular as balenciaga yeah yeah
so i could see how a person who's an
amazing comment would succeed in an
industry that is a con
yeah i again i think amazing musician i
just want to point that out
amazing musician and and trump isn't
music
his is entertainment he's just an
entertainer through and through like
you can't talk for an hour and a half in
front of an audience with with
no script without being an incredible
entertainer yeah and
they both have their amazing
entertainment thing
and they use the equity equity they have
in that
to spread into these other industries
that they probably don't know anything
about and you probably argue that trump
is like exceptional real estate too
you could say that i don't think it's as
ill-intentioned necessarily i don't
think it's fully planned
again we both have a friend we he
struggles with bipolarity i saw him go
through it and i remember when he got
out of the mental hospital
he said if i didn't take meds and you
let me just go i would have created some
unbelievable [ __ ]
and we were like what are you talking
about he's not he's like nah man you
don't understand when you're manic
you're just going and going and going
and you're spewing and creating and like
some of that [ __ ] is going to be
brilliant it just is now it's not worth
the inevitable crash but it's some of
it's going to be brilliant and i don't
think he
intentionally lily pads i think he's
internet educated
and he's going and going and going he's
taking one factoid from this thing and
one factoid from that thing and one
factoid from that thing but
the guy is clearly crazy and it's i'm a
religious guy but i don't like when
we're like
oh god fix that god can take care of
whatever issues you have that's god no
god and science can go together yo
yeah you can believe in god and still
need meds and that's the thing yeah the
his big turn towards religion right now
it seems a little it's just new to me
i'm not a religious person so like i get
put off by that
but it's like his motivation used to be
becoming that dude becoming the top dude
becoming rich become like
now it seems like okay i already reached
the top
and so his main focus everything he kept
going back on is how can i improve
society how can i help people
i want to become the leader of the free
world so i can help people i want to
create this sustainable society so i can
help people
like and and yeah he hasn't helped
anybody
that's the thing it's like you can argue
his family his in-laws have actually
hurt the world
his focus was him first now it just
seems like his direction is helping
people now
yo give big sean back his masters bruh
all your artists back their masters and
that's the thing that's the thing we
he got to see it like only time will
tell when it comes to him
i do agree that yes he is a selfish
person and he cares about himself first
and
then it's like this big talk but like
right now
it it seems a little genuine you know
i'm being it seems like a genuine crazy
person i'm gonna say something might be
wild
i don't think he's a billionaire bro now
he is they they proved it
forbes said it so i believe it that's
that's all i have
how do they prove it i'm curious it's
like being worth it right
it's an evaluation of the company right
yeah that's what it is it's an
evaluation of the company
if he leaves that company do you think
yeezy's still worth anything
but that's let's say that that's more to
set an evaluation you can say that about
so many things
no cash out and then leave if the guy
who owns coca-cola leaves coca-cola
we still drinking coca-cola yeah but
he's not just gonna leave with nothing
he's gonna cash out and then leave i
don't think anybody's paying three
billion dollars for
yeezy if easy's not part of it so i
think he stays on as something something
he has to stay on
i don't think he could sell his company
get the three billion dollars you can
sell your company and stay on though
like
it does but i'm saying i don't think he
can actually access and hold those three
billion dollars and the only way he can
is if he sells his company
he can sell some shares though yeah yeah
he can sell enough shares and then they
keep him on an advisory role and he's
still associated with it
like you know what i mean jordan can't
leave jump man that don't make jordan
not a billionaire he could like sell
equity and still stay on the board i
think like bill gates did that [ __ ]
i don't know if he's a billionaire bro
it just seems weird to me like why are
you gonna
why are you gonna resign a 10 million
dollar contract with def jam if you're a
billionaire like
y'all know how much money a billion
dollars is bro you're gonna bicker over
it
you have a billion dollars you're
bickering with def jam
over a 10 million dollar contract being
worth something and having that is two
different things that's he don't got a
billion dollars that's what i'm saying
yeah
worth he doesn't say that yo son i'm
worth a billion dollars
i mean wait what happened no i'm worth
it that's what i believe i'm worth
i'm worth 10 billion dollars my
valuation is literally 100
100 billion dollars 100 billion 100
billion dollars
that's my evaluation bro i mean i'm a
hundred billion dollars forbes agrees
i'll agree
why forbes who the [ __ ] is forbes what
is somebody you don't know
there's somebody i'm worth i'm worth a
hundred billion dollars
also i'm saying like we could all
evaluate ourselves or whatever we want
and that makes you the second richest
man on earth
who's the richest i think bezos at 113.
i'm 114 billion
wait i evaluated myself with that you
want to buy me it's 114.
what just made it go up bezos
finding that out about bezos i thought i
was clear spike in the market
no i really thought that i was clear bro
i guess my point is like
he's i'm a billionaire you can't access
that billions i don't think that he
could actually hold a billion cash
i think he can get to it but he doesn't
have it now he can get i don't know
so what kylie did kylie was a
majority shareholder in that makeup line
she marketed it it grew and now it was
worth more than a couple billion
and then she sold a big percentage of
her stake i think
for like 800 and something million
dollars so she actually had that in
cash and she still has to stay on to
promote the makeup line to keep it going
can we piss before i move on before we
move on yes i just
i feel like kanye is a
genuinely crazy person who's actually
sincere about the things that he says
i can see him crazy though i don't think
it's his own intention yeah
as you think i don't think it's as con
artisty as you i'll buy it i think he's
a con artist i think he's got mental
illness there's no doubt that he has
mental illness
but yeah but you haven't seen like this
before yeah it's like we've seen this so
many times and it's so calculated and
everything is so
but you know why people are against it
now why because he's not rooting for
black people anymore
oh well that's the other thing i think
the only reason he got religious is to
get black people back
and i think he's like what's the easiest
way to get black people back black
people are very religious black people
are christians
i'm a rock with this christianity thing
i'm gonna do it you know better than
anybody how am i gonna do christianity
i'm gonna do it with the thing i do at
best
music and then people arrive with it
everybody's excited about this
you know when i was talking about the
production value on that jesus album and
i was like i vividly remember alex and
it's not good production
oh yeah yeah it wasn't but his heart
isn't in the music anymore that my
opinion
yeah you like late late registration
late registration fantastic he's talking
about his jesus album
the gospel god is king or whatever
anyway we don't have to we don't have to
keep talking about connie what are we
going to say mark
no hey we don't have to keep talking
about kanye i'm just very skeptical of
him
and he had the perfect platform to
really like
express how he feels and how
misunderstood he was and joe gave him
all the [ __ ] rope that he needed bro
like literally like
hey joe gave him the benefit of the
doubt with absolutely everything
yeah and to me wasn't committed and the
tmz thing kanye said
van tweeted this is [ __ ] is not what
happened yeah